MARK:
Hello everybody,
my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to the
Water War challenge by J fowl?
MATTHIAS:
J Fall.
MARK:
MATTHIAS:
J Fall.
MARK:
Oh, Jimmy Fallon.
MATHIAS: yeah
MARK: oh ok
So we're playing
the Water War challenge.
Basically if you've
played War in your cards,
we each flip a card over,
whoever has the highest wins,
whoever has the lowest though,
is the most important,
because they lose.
And the person with
the highest card gets to dump...
these are our lives
'cause they are
filled with ice water.
Not really ice any more
'cause it's hot out here,
but they're cold water,
and we're gonna dump 'em
on the person(painfully).
We're here with Team Edge,
and we're gonna play.
You guys ready?
MATTHIAS:
I'm ready!
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3, flip!
Ace, baby.
RYAN:
Damn it!
MARK
Wait, is Ace a one,
or ace is top?
MATTHIAS:
Ace is high 420 BLAZE IT
RYAN:
Rock paper scissors that then.
BRYAN and MATT:
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Ok, it's you, it's you.
MARK:
Alright.
MATTHIAS:
You guys both
chose the same thing.
J-FRED:
Right in the face, man!(Thats what he said).
BRYAN:
Oh yeah!(thats what your uncle said).
MATTHIAS:
It's pretty cold, right!(come on guys give me a break here)
BRYAN:
Oh yeah!(just close you eyes and laugh like a little schoolgirl)
MARK:
Hang on,
I got my phone in my pocket.
MATT:
Oh you're just making it bad.
MATTHIAS:
That was cruel.
RYAN:
It's like a forper.
MARK:
Alright, ready?
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3.
MARK:
Oh, Joker!
The joker gets to dump on
whoever he feels like.
MATTHIAS:
Yeah, just dump on whoever.
MATT:
This is a tricky decision.(just keep your eyes closed
RYAN:
Is it?
MARK:
Is it really?(yes really)
(laughing)
MATTHIAS:
Mamacita, that's cold.
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3, flip!
Yeah buddy!
J-FRED:
Matthias!
MATTHIAS:
What, I lost with a seven!?
Conveniently,
whoever shuffled wins.
BRYAN:
Everyone saw me shuffle.
MATTHIAS:
No, this happened last time.
J-FRED:
On our channel.
MATT:
I'll take your cards.
MATTHIAS:
Ok you're dead.
You're dead to me.(insert asdf meme)
Absolutely dead to me.
MARK:
Ryan, your place in Team Edge
is solidified!
RYAN:
Yeah!
MARK:
Hey!
Don't be a
poor sport there, buddy.
MATTHIAS:
You're dead to me.
RYAN:
Get it?
It was a Pour sport.(No just no)
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3, flip!
MATT:
Ah damn it.
J-FRED:
Yeah!
Who got the lowest?(Penis?)
MATT:
Alright, bring it over.(time to close your eyes again!)
(laughing)
MATTHIAS:
Wait, why were you so pleased?
(grunting)
RYAN:
Daddy likes.
MARK:
We're doing great
on this side of the table.(ok open them)
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1, flip.
MARK:
Oh!
He's got a three too!
MATT:
3, 2, 1.
MARK:
Yeah!
RYAN:
You're the lowest.
Here we go.
J-FRED:
Face cards, right Bryan?
(laughing)
MATT:
I was expecting the head.
MATTHIAS and RYAN:
Did it get in your mouth?(your making this to easy guys... thats also what she said)
MATTHIAS:
Oh!
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3, flip!
MATTHIAS:
Oh, oh, oh, right.
Another face card.
Come on.
BRYAN:
You guys all saw me shuffle.
MARK:
Yeah, we saw you shuffle badly.
J-FRED:
Wait, Matt lost again?
MATT:
Come on, no.
Ah, stop stop!
You're doing it so slow.
(laughing)
MATT:
Why?
RYAN:
Ok ready?
BRYAN:
1, 2, 3.
MATTHIAS:
Ok, right, right.
MARK:
That is suspicious.
(scream)(oh come on)
J-FRED:
It hasn't reached.
It pooled.
MARK:
It's pooling.
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1, flip.
MARK:
Yeah!
(laughing)
J-FRED:
No, just do it.
Aah!
Its so cold.
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1.
MARK:
You did that on purpose.
I got nerves of steel.
Aah.
MATT:
Back of the shirt.
J-FRED:
Oh that's rough.
Very slowly.
MARK:
Aah, it's down the back!
(laughing)
BRYAN:
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
MARK:
What is this?
What did you do to me?
MATT:
Mark, it's the luck of the draw.
MARK:
No it's not.
MATTHIAS:
You just said it,
'the luck of the draw'
right before you were losing.
(grunting)
MATTHIAS:
Your remix of those sounds.
(grunting)
MARK:
If this is another
god damn two...
MATT:
Mark you watched me shuffle.
RYAN:
Two twos in a row.
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1.
J-FRED:
Oh come now.
Dang it I lost.
MATT:
How many twos are there?
BRYAN:
Dang it.
MARK:
Dang it, there goes
my face card, but ok.
I shall give you
a merciful death.(nothing is merciful about cold water)
(laughing)
MATTHIAS:
A merciful- Just destroy him.(excactly matthias
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1.
MATTHIAS:
No- oh!
MARK:
Ok, you go.
If you do.
MATTHIAS:
Yeah!
MARK:
I know you all have been
waiting for this moment.
MATT:
Remember how evil he was.
MATTHIAS:
Remember.
BRYAN:
That's messed up.
MATT:
You did that to me.
BRYAN:
Oh no.
There's a lot of water in this-.
MARK:
This cup is really full.
BRYAN:
Alright ready, 1, 2, 3.
J-FRED:
What're you, a boy scout?
BRYAN:
Yes!
MARK:
This is bologna.
Malarky.
J-FRED:
Bryan every time.
BRYAN:
At least you guys can't accuse
me of cheating at all now.
MARK:
Have mercy.
MATTHIAS:
Oh!
BRYAN:
Mark's out.
MARK:
What whatever.(don't be a boy scout take it like a man!)
BRYAN:
Ryan, Matt.
1, 2, 3, flip!
Oh Ryan.
MARK:
Make his family feel this
for generations to come.
RYAN:
Oh no.
(laughing)
RYAN:
That was smart.
(laughing)
MATTHIAS:
Didn't really slowly release.
MARK:
Chinese water torture.(before he said he was being merciful hmmmm)
MATTHIAS:
Ready, set, go.
Dang it.
I lose, I lose,
this is it for me.
Good bye.
I loved you all!(tell his pet (insert animal)he loved it!)
(yelling)
MATTHIAS:
Oh I thought it was done!
MARK:
I don't think it's gonna matter.
MATT:
I bet it's gonna be Bryan.
BRYAN:
Yes!
MATTHIAS:
Of course.
He really set himself up
for that one, didn't he?(Bryan was the spy the whole time!)
MARK:
Would've won if it wasn't
for the draw that he had.
RYAN:
That water smells.
BRYAN:
That's it!
Who was out first?
MARK:
Well anyway, that was Water War.
Thank you so much for watching,
and thank you for joining us,
Team Edgy
J-FRED:
Wait, it's not over though.9(PLOT TWIST!)
BRYAN:
We have to peg him
with a water balloon.(oh i see hehe)
MARK:
Oh bonus content!
BRYAN:
3, 2, 1.
MATTHIAS:
Fire!
MATT:
Oh they hurt!
Oh!
(laughing)
MARK:
Ok, so that was the end
of Water War.
Thank you everybody
so much for watching,
thank you Team Edge
for having us over,and special credit to Haven spikes for narrating the entire vid for us!
and look on their channel
for another video
of this action(not on Haven's channel)
coming at you real soon.
Thanks again, everybody.
See you in the next one.
Buh-bye!